for anybody who is trying to do this
it's quantity first so you just have to
put out a lot of stuff and you do a lot
of stuff not because you're going to get
a lot of reach from it but because you
don't know what you're doing it gives
you two things one is it gives you
feedback from the audience because
there's gonna be some stuff that does
better than others and so it's like cool
do more of that and then you start to
learn how to increase the quality that's
like doing the more of that good stuff
you start studying the things that are
outliers that do a little bit better and
I think the third phase is quality
quantity where you can put out amazing
videos and then more of them